okay
hello everyone
welcome to another
modern language design review
part of our language completeness and
consistency series
so it looks like we have a super simple
agenda today
sir what's that I was just saying
right
let's try and Tackle this one first
because I think it might be quick
right so right there's this extra space
at the bottom of a data set which was
annoying me when I was trying to put the
data set in a notebook and so on
right and the reason it's there is right
there's this hover which gives you the
keys right so if you hover over the mass
of the most
um then you will see that drop down
there right so that's all Mars
etc etc
now we kind of annoying to have to have
to leave that space for this
um what about this area up here
what's the problem with leaving that
space I mean it seems like I I think
when you put these things in a column or
when I had them in a notebook where you
have text above and below them it's
annoyingly
you know I would argue that putting him
in a column you should not like data
sets are not designed to be in columns I
think data sets are designed to be kind
of on their own in a cell
yeah but even when they're on their own
cell the cell below them is further away
than the cell above them
right so you know at one at one point I
I'm not sure we ever put this in a
shipping version but certainly at one
one point right we had this dotted frame
around
the whole data set and then it was very
clear what was there that was even more
bizarre
um because it had that big empty space
at the bottom
right yeah I mean I suppose the
um
oh but I can ask so I don't recall
having been involved in discussions
about this but there are definitely
other forms of notifications that could
happen
I mean it could go in the status bar for
the notebook it could go in an attached
cell that floats over other contents
right and I I do I do mention that right
we cannot reserve the space of course
then it might crash into whatever is
beneath it which maybe we don't care
because it'll disappear as soon as you
move the mouse and you just we just give
it a white background or something right
we give it an appropriate background
having it overlay what's below it is a
perfectly good idea I mean it's it's not
unlikely what we do with uh you know
with like image cells for example where
you where in that case it's a click not
a hover but you know we're okay with the
click producing a you know tool which
can overlap content below it
how do I make an image of a certain side
uh one comma
and well it's one comma Dimensions yeah
one common dimensions
and so now if you click the image see
see that's allowed to overlap and that's
okay that's just fine I don't see a
problem with that I mean sometimes
annoys me but I know how to get out of
it
I think that's what we should do for
data set
go there
and it extrudes a thing that that sort
of floats over what the content below
I'm okay with that
what sort of stuff is getting put in
that space at the bottom it's the key
that gives you that element right so so
float over the massive Phobos
or or or or demos whichever
um right so that's right it's giving you
Mars moons Phobos if you click over the
mass it gives you mass and you you'll
see that that input right below it I
have data set of Mars moons Phobos mass
and it right so it's giving you the
parts that will allow you to extract
that thing programmatically
which I get I mean that's useful
especially right like if you scroll down
and you know click on the moons of
Jupiter so so you will actually be in
the nested thing right it is sort of
useful right so if you click on the more
or wherever there is the number this 62
total right that's useful to be able to
see that breadcrumb
quite wide has a space before Jupiter I
don't know
oh and this is another argument for it
being a an overlay is that what if this
thing is too narrow for the path
yes yeah and and
yeah yeah it's uh the size is actively
changing I would rather the size didn't
change look at that yeah
all right I think that's no I was just
wondering you know if you want something
that's at the bottom if you want
something that's closer to the element
that you're
inspecting well the problem is uh most
of what you can do interactively is with
a right click so if you had a tooltip or
something that would be I I know I guess
you could have it click through and
but it would be a little weird I think
maybe not
uh Jose you're our biggest user of data
sets here do you have an opinion on that
point
not really
no I think we should just do the
Extrusion overlay thing
okay I I okay before we go go on to Echo
functions I did have a question which is
so go back to
um so like click on moons
there
right and so right I created this with
Max items goes to four so we only saw
four planets at a time but now that I
clicked on it I expected to see four
moons with a scroll bar but instead I
see this is wrong okay in my opinion
yeah I mean if you said max items
because you you know you want to see
that number of items
yeah it does does anybody disagree or or
have a different take
I mean I just wanted to make
make sure that this isn't some quote
unquote feature that I don't understand
because I'm not a heavy data set user
but I found this very surprising
seems surprising to me I got a comment
here that that we might have graphic
design take another look at these icons
they just have an awful that has an
awful sense of um you know exclusive
orism
okay
you you are I think quite unusual and
not necessarily in mistaking it for
something else but in mistaking it for
exclusive or you're quite unusual
it's got the bar on the wrong side but
yeah
I wouldn't look at that I can't say why
is there an exclusive or button on my
data set I I I I mean heck I came
through in Computer Engineering and I'm
thinking is he mistaking it maybe for uh
a cloud floating on top of a mountain
actually it'd be nice to pick up the
motif of these
Rose here and have something where this
is overlaid on top of a bunch of of sort
of rows I think that might make it
clearer what's going on here over late
over a bunch of rows I'm not I didn't
quite follow that well so what I mean is
you have an arrow up but it is somehow
the background is somehow this thing
that shows that it is going up by rows
somehow
um
just a suggestion for design
okay I want to raise another thing which
I'm sorry we haven't got on the agenda
today and that is my
um Graphics padding Summit
Brett could do you I mean let me clarify
you know what I mean by the graphics
padding Summit I I know parts of it at
least but and we've had we've had
versions of it so but I wasn't and we
made some decisions but I wasn't aware
that there were news I mean I think you
know the last I heard you were
interested in like you know do you you
know every possible source of padding
um that goes into graphics and that sort
of thing excuse me
an interested in padding theorems so to
speak
in other words if you combine this with
that there will be no space there'll
always be a fixed space What will there
be
see what I'm saying
um
which I think right now is a mess
and I think it's a mess because the
theorem you know the theorem might
include oh you can have a font there and
it will do this and so on and so on and
so on
but you know we just need this very
precise way of talking about all these
things
that makes sense because
you know we have these things where
there's an amount of padding that's left
because oh there might be a font on this
side we don't know how big it is it's
rendered at you know it's it's
determinate rendering time blah blah
blah
and this is relevant because
with Native Graphics coming to the cloud
there's yet another redo of all these
kinds of things and They're copying
every design feature app
indeed
um
I mean I think the case where
I'm get most annoyed is in graphics
grids where things are just like
ridiculous amounts of space are getting
left
and I don't know why
I mean
if I pick
if I make a um
something like this okay so I say
Graphics of rectangle
um
and then I say image size
Arrow random
real
let's say
um
that's
okay
okay now
okay so I don't even understand what the
hell's that oh that's a oh that's
because it's a rectangle of that shape
okay so that's padded
you need to add frames to these it's
impossible to tell whether they're
reasonable without them
okay
right because you're you're not changing
the aspect ratio right so
if you did the aspect ratio goes to
automatic then it would be tight around
the rectangle but then they'd all be
identical I suppose
no I think you need a background
you made me just say framed around the
outside I don't think that frame is
going where you think it is
yeah I agree
change the frame to Background by Blue
okay
all right now
let me put these in a graphics grid
well but but okay I mean are there any
of these that you're complaining about
the initial ones there's a background
events yeah that was going to be my
question
it's really weird that is weird but I
see the background I see blue
yeah there's just a hint of blue
so something goofed up here but also I
mean this just isn't right look at this
I mean if I say
I mean
they're right they're all the same
they're all the same size right where
did the Blues come from just now
well he's using grid rather than
Graphics okay
right right so so so I mean right if you
if you hop away the background which is
going around right the spacings are
basically the same between those two
maybe it's a bit smaller in the grid so
yeah why has it got extra stuff in the
in the graphics grid
there isn't it's just that it's just
well no no there is a little bit right I
mean if you if we if we measure the
number of pixels between you know the
bottom left
square and the square right above it
um then
resize the graphic oh
he did didn't he yeah okay so well what
what the hell's going on here why does
some of the plot ranges are changing too
and you rescale it
like like if you rescale it look at the
very first one top left you can see the
blue region changes in size well I think
I think that's just aspect ratio right
it all it has an aspect ratio and then
so the blue is
you know it's preserving trimmed right
let's go and trim down and look in the
theorem
so to speak the frame is gone
so our you know open interval closed
interval you know something went wrong
and the frame is gone now
I was just wrong right we agree it's
wrong that the frame disappears in this
case right
yes
okay so somewhere something you know so
what happened that caused that to occur
I mean as soon as you start having stuff
outside of Graphics yeah this is a very
difficult case to reason about
the the wrapping of the framed around it
that makes it very hard to reason about
but it still should work
I mean give me a reason why it shouldn't
work so I mean it's it's like you did
Graphics grid of a table of strings
yes
and why wouldn't that work
what does it mean yeah what does it mean
right we have to make a choice of how to
convert those strings into graphics and
blah blah blah
and oftentimes your answering and
strings have absolute sizing components
sure
right right the head of a the head the
output of a graphics grid is a grid okay
it's a graphics I this is what is what I
was actually trying to say not a grid
which means right these things that
don't net right strings don't naturally
live I mean I suppose you can wrap them
in text and give them coordinates and
then they naturally live in graphics but
they don't in and of themselves
naturally live inside of Graphics
expression so choices have to be made
about how to embed them and in our
Graphics by default even when they are
in graphics Expressions they're sized
absolutely
unless you do something to change that
okay so now what are we seeing here
so yeah so that's there in traditional
forms so so the single ones are
italicized
okay
but so now and so what you have done by
wrapping framed around the individual
Graphics is
certainly created some overlap with this
example okay so wait a second so what
happened here why did that funk out oh
because it's a line wrap yes yeah
and it's and it's right it's forcing a
size so yeah it made some choice about
how wide things are gonna it thinks
they're gonna be and then
you made them smaller so something why
is this not resize the grid to be able
to fit it
what does it mean
it's it's absolutely size tax
you didn't do anything to change so if I
make the grids more absolutely smaller
I'm toast
yeah
okay
but so
so explain to me again why is this
getting cut off do you know I mean
I mean what what I'm saying is it's
actually pretty hard to reason about
right so it's hard to give a definitive
answer
short answer it's getting cut off
because
it's going outside the edges of the
inset that was constructed for it yes
why exactly I don't know okay but do you
think that's a bug
not necessarily not necessarily I mean
because because there is a frame box
sitting in between there
it's it's it's not a pure graphic
anymore
experientially it's a bug it's it's it's
it's like it's it's a uh of the same
order of thing as if you did square root
of the graphic or X plus the graphic or
something like that
you know it's if it were a pure graphic
there would be you know more consistent
levers that we could control but when
you throw it into the uh 2D typesetting
world you know 2D type setting does not
want to be resized in that way
right it's like right I mean if you if
you use the frame option which obviously
will behave very differently that's
something that lives inside of the
graphics which is different from framed
of graphic which puts a thing around the
whole graphics
why didn't this do what I expected it to
do
uh
well that
is square root defined for image
oh oh it might be applying it to the
elements and the elements are all but
they're not all zeros or ones
uh right right we do have a such a thing
as image arithmetic yeah we do
so um I I presume it's applying now what
I can't tell you I mean I can understand
why zeros are right if you only had
white and black yeah yeah oh well it
might be that these are RGB all in RGB
under all zeros and ones right I think
that's right I think that that's the
problem yeah amusing how do I get the
function which doesn't matter well you
know add a half to it right that should
work
absolutely
okay cool
um okay in any case back to this
I'm still coming back to experientially
this is a bug right so what happens is
you know when you evaluate Graphics grid
it's you know especially in this case
where you have framed of graphics
it measures in some sense what the size
of that is
and then I think this was the one that
you resized right
I'm sure that caused the clipping well
let's let's see it okay let's see what
happens if I give it an absolute image
size
now what exactly are you claiming is the
bug
this is missing yeah okay
which may be does that have a half of a
frame Edge on the right right right that
that also could possibly be an aliasing
issue right that you know yeah
I mean the fact that all the clippings
are right on the frame Edge
suggest to me that there could be a
second issue at play here
um
which is not
interesting for purposes of this
discussion but you think it's just a bug
it's absolutely a bug possibly I think
it's a complicated question I think
that's why we need theorems about
padding because I think it's a question
of you know an open interval a closed
interval do you include the boundary
those kinds of things
well I mean this is the kind of thing
that we we get those deal with all the
time
in in in in in the front end we deal
with this kind of stuff all the time
it's it's part of our bread and butter
um uh but we we have a a history of uh
you know in some cases doing some
um arithmetical rounding to uh to get
things to line up on the pixel grid and
uh that was a great thing to do when
everybody's monitors look the same
um in the 90s and the odds but uh uh now
you know we no longer have a reliable
pixel grid that we can snap to and it's
uh not we can't even assume that a pixel
grid on the same machine is consistent
it might be different from Monitor to
Monitor and so yes all three of my
monitors are quite different in that
respect yeah so we're actually in the
process of uh uh of extricating
ourselves from that uh uh mess that we
you know spent decades getting into
um
okay so do you think this will I mean
this is a bug so we've got to figure out
right so so so if what we're seeing here
is just of the nature of it just trimmed
the very edges and that's it then I
think it might be that kind of bug okay
but uh but but the bigger issue you were
raising is uh you resize and it does you
know kind of really fundamentally
different things that's uh that's the
different question which is interesting
okay but I also have another Point
there's too much space here why is there
so much space here and not so much space
here I think well I think because the
all the squares are sized the same and
so because that row only has not very
tall things in it you don't that's not
how grid Works grid doesn't do that no
but
uh nothing else just look at the widest
element in each column you know and then
the tallest element inch row and every
element in each phone column has to you
know be at least that big I know but
there's nothing there's no descender
here that goes into the white space
there's a big gutter here with no
descender going into it why is there
such a gutter
right I mean the literal reason is is
that all the rows are the same height
that's one of the differences between
Graphics grid and normal grid
isn't it I don't know it's not supposed
to be
Brett uh I mean that's what I've how
I've been interpreting what I see but I
I and I assumed that was intended
I don't remember off the top of my head
and
all right well okay because because
there's like I mean and I would claim I
would claim that right if you if you
look at a grid of you know at like a
gallery icon or or a gallery icon an
icon gallery or or some sort any sort of
image gallery uh typically it's
certainly very common and I would claim
the usual case is that you know all all
it's all the rows and columns are are
are the same height and width and you
know the icon takes up however much
space in that that it wants right so if
I presume you can do like dividers goes
to all in graphics grid is that
something yes
right and then we would see that you
know we have exactly the same behavior
of a standard
uh image gallery where they're all the
same height
no they're not well look at these some
of these lines are thicker than others
if I'm not mistaken
uh I don't they're not drawn that way so
I mean if they're rendering that way
that's
it there is some confusing stuff though
because like look at the first top left
too why are they not taller oh that's
what I'm wondering right now is why
okay so I I just came across uh
something interesting uh let me throw a
couple of examples and chat for you to
evaluate
sorry no no not that that
um
there so
that
and then compare
to the same thing with dividers all
now now just just cotton just copy down
but add dividers all to the graphics
grid
there is an interesting difference here
which I had not at all expected
weird
right it's leaving space above the top
row of things Brett I think they're just
bugs here I'm telling you we need
I I agree there are bugs you know I'm
halfway tracked down some for you know
Graphics row
you know a bit ago and haven't been able
to you know haven't come back around to
pick it up again but all right I well
yes I will um I mean I will also submit
the thought that you know the theorems
you are searching for May you know we
might take us 350 pages to prove that
one plus one equals two
right I mean
what do you mean I mean the theorem I'm
looking for is a statement that
for example
if you ever be more space left than
needs to be left in this situation there
will always be enough space to render
the boundary
those kinds of things
I and my assertion that defining in this
situation may take you as long you know
what could potentially take us as long
as it took Hilbert to prove that one
plus one equals two
I think not Hilbert that was that was uh
that was a uh yes Whitehead and Russell
yes I meant I meant Russell uh that was
just them showing off but anyway never
mind that uh
okay
well my experience with that is that
you're gonna spend a lot of time on
those last pixels getting those right
right okay I mean we've got to have some
axiomatic claims like for example
probably this violates an axiomatic
claim like adding dividers shouldn't
change the uh you know the range of the
graphic
adding a phrase are you saying that
right so so we're saying so those two
inputs are the same except for the
dividers goes to all it's what you're
telling us and uh and we're getting very
different yes I think we can all agree
that's a bug
um
I mean I I'm
I can't promise but I have a strong
feeling that I was told that
you know you know spacing above the
element you know depends on
that top frame Edge
no
so the question is which one is the bug
you know if if you know the claim is
that it's a bug
well the other question is why is there
so much space around these things to
begin with why are they not further down
here
that I'm not sure about I mean I think
that comes back to for whatever reason
Graphics grid is making all the things
the same height
um I don't think it is I don't think
that's generally true
well it's been sure
what's the default alignment center
Center
okay in which case I feel like that's a
bug
that that the top one is a bug if the
default alignment is Center and not
something like automatic or
whatever then I I don't see how you can
CL you know reasonably claim that you
know that that top square and circle are
are Center I mean what are they center
right most of those things can't be
centered as my claim
those two both of those rows can't be
centered so if the default alignment is
centered then that is a bug is my clay
right
but I will also claim right I mean you
know if we think about all the different
things that we're sticking into these
Graphics grids right right there is uh
image margins you know padding frame
margins shrink crap goes to true or
false you know there are probably 17
different options
and I'm not even sure that that's an
exaggeration that are all all
potentially interacting with each other
here and so proving a theorem when you
have those many options is going to be
quite difficult
okay but but the question of what
there's no equal in the case of grid
there's an option called
um equal elements or something what's it
called
um
I have no idea what you're talking about
to be honest I I do but I'm just not
remembering
um there used to be a columns equal in
rows equal it is now instead a setting
for item size yeah but I can't remember
what the setting is
um it's documented
all
okay well so is there a corresponding
thing for
um Graphics I don't think there is for
graphics great maybe you know that will
help there's no item size
all right anyway I'm telling you there's
something's wrong here and we could I'm
not disputing that
um
okay he's saying he doesn't want to work
on it because it's really painful I know
well okay and you know now you're gonna
run out of time for all the good Echo
stuff but anyway let's go back together
okay let's turn to Echo
what was it all right echo echo was some
character in Greek mythology
I don't remember yes you mean like a
glyph character
narcissus or something
could be
right so you know we propose you know at
some meeting which may well be like four
months ago now given the number of times
this agenda item has been delayed
um
right we we provisionally came up right
well but we're we're not going to skip
straight ahead to the goals this time
we're going to actually go into thinking
about some of the details right so we
came up with you know a bunch of these
things which I think is probably a few
too many but also we should think
through about what it is we actually
want out of some of these so for example
Echo limit was a request from
Christopher uh which was to have
something like uh dollar output size
limit for Echo
um yes and I mean my first claim is that
this has to be called Echo size limit or
nobody will understand what it is
um uh but and then a you know there
there there's a conceptual question of
should just this be the same output size
limit
um but there's also a sort of a deeper
philosophical issue is that output size
limit works
inherently by the fact that everything
is assigned to out right if you if if
you have
um right if dollar history length is
zero outputs I mean I suppose the output
size limiter will fire and you'll see a
short thing but you'll never be able to
do anything with it is that correct Lou
I guess I should have tried that before
this meeting that that's what should
happen yes
um right and so you know all this
functionality depends on the fact that
it can refer all the nice things other
than the fact that it's short depend on
the fact that that expression is still
stored somewhere namely in out
um I understand and so then the question
is
what do we do for Echo and that we have
sort of a similar issue with just print
and you know maybe we say print is low
level and we don't care about it but
Echo
I feel like you know okay so I've got a
suggestion okay in the output size
limited there is an interactive way to
get everything
you're saying it's very nice that you
don't need the interactive way to get
everything because you still bound it to
something but Echo no no no no no no no
no no it's more than that it couldn't
actually be implemented to get
everything if it weren't there in in the
down value yeah I got it I got it I got
it but I mean so my claim is okay so
your point is
that when Echo comes out it's
transmitting in the blind so to speak
and it doesn't have any it's not it's
not there's nothing there's no there
there's no thing there it's just
splitting out this message and
forgetting it it's ephemeral yeah yeah
yep
um
it's no
right it's no different than if you did
you know cell print of you know fives or
expression cell of five right that that
creates a cell that has five but five
isn't stored anywhere
you know that that the kernel exactly
yeah
what's an analogy to this
um
I mean it's clearly useful to have an
echo size look what is the print
what is the analogous thing for printing
what is it called what is the limiter
called what's the thing that determines
the default limit
there is no analogous thing for printing
I mean dollar message preprint or no no
no no I mean the thing what determines
when you get a too big thing in printing
and and just regular or you mean an
output an output
right so there there's right there's a
hook and dollar preprint that checks if
the
uh you know if the expression is Big
which is again uh which is also a very
complicated and and
you know something we could spend just
as we could have a whole Summit about
the definition of big there but okay if
if it determines that it's too big
rather than allowing it to just format
normally it formats this output size
limiter which shows you sort of the
short version of it with all the extra
buttons to
oh yeah I guess but there's no dollar
output size limit
you can set well there is it's called
dollar output size limit
oh and and
it you know you can send set it in the
front-end preferences even
okay so dollar Echo size limit would
refer to the same thing the maximum size
in bytes blah blah blah right
but the thing that you're commenting on
is that in an output size limit
foreign
oh yeah that that shortened output size
limiter uh in the previous input if you
look at it right so you yes yes yes
I'm sure I can get it the limit at some
point
okay
why isn't that limiting
uh
huh that's
boom limited yeah yeah
okay by the way that's the thing to feed
to Brian on the documentation team the
fact that that wasn't caught was the
thing that had to be regenerated
yep got it
um
okay
so
the question is
if we do the corresponding thing for
Echo
we could have some kind of
you know this has been shortened type
indicator
but we can't have a show more correct
well I still think it's worthwhile
it's it's very similar to what we're
doing with error handling right now I
mean you know if we or message handling
I should be more specific the message
just doesn't come out if it's more than
the third message and if you were hoping
to see the messages beyond that you
literally have no choice but to
reevaluate the input
yeah
fine fine
so dollar Echo size limit seems like
it's quite sensible too
um and the only thing is the visual
question of what it looks like
uh
and and does it also apply is it does it
apply to the sum of the bytes of the
label and the thing that was printed oh
good I don't know I would say just the
thing that's printed
yeah I mean that that's my instinct as
well for for one thing you a labels are
expected to be small B you have full
control over that so
okay what should it do what should it
look like should it do this lozengy type
thing or what should we do
um I'm not sure we have something
much better than that well fine but we
might as well use something consistent
with this we'll need a lightweight
version of these things without the
footer
right
okay
all right let's move on yeah okay we got
that yep let's go temporary and limit
Echo
right uh and you know my I mean we would
need to do some implementation work but
I think rather than
um
having you know a limit Echo and the
dollar Max Echo limit and all that right
we already have Echo quiet
a quiet Echo yes
uh
uh so if we implemented hold all sub
values which is something we've talked
about wanting
we could just turn quiet Echo into an
operator form
and with like I show in that input there
and I think that's probably a better
Direction than adding several similarly
named
symbols that are slightly different
I
think let's just see whether we can
reduce the number of symbols that we
care about to a small number
okay
so what are the okay so I I do want to
go about thinking about that
well
I think that this
I think what's important is
this concept here I think that's more
important than this concept here
but it's a little Annoying that you
would have to say
I'm saying I mean this is when you're
putting in the Echo
you're thinking
oh I want to show this while it's
evaluating and then I want it to go away
in fact what is the difference between
now that I'm looking at this again
what's the difference between Echo
temporary and cleanup Echo okay Echo
temporary means this Echo that I am
generating right here
actually is an echo
but it's a temporary one right right
okay clean up Echo is there were echoes
there will be Echoes made here but when
this is finished evaluating get rid of
them right yes now I remember
and remember I prepared this agenda item
and I still got it confused which is why
I'm saying there are too many symbols
so for cleanup Echo would that clean up
Echoes that were pre-existing the call
into cleanup echo or
just Echoes generated
inside the cleanup Echo
right so somehow it would have you know
the guys that are inside the the ones
that come from expert will need to
somehow tag themselves as we came from
expert so that when cleanup Echo runs
clean up Echo could simply do a lexical
replacement of every every Echo is
replaced by I think that Echo should
just block some variable that then each
Echo function yeah I'm I mean I I I I I
guess I didn't mean that literally I I
wasn't trying to get into there there
right we can all think of at least four
different possible implementations which
I I don't think is the important point
my but the point I was trying to stress
is that yes the the the cleanup Echo
specifically looks for The Echoes that
are associated with the expression
inside of it so you could you know both
Talk use cases okay Echo temporary I see
as being something that I would
routinely put into code
just as a an El Cheapo progress monitor
right and you know by necessity it would
sort of have to you know apply to an
entire shift enter evaluation
yes well I mean that that that that that
that is a that is a question right the
uh right presumably Echo temporary
removes things when
uh you know when the current line is
finished you know it could be made it
could have an option for
you know
allowed Echoes a type option
where Echo temporary
just looks at the echoes in sequence and
starts removing them
you know keeps only the most recent and
echoes
so that it really looks is it like a
progress monitor but maybe that's better
to be done with the panel maybe it's
better to be done by something that
looks like our progress framework
I mean okay how do you get okay you're
writing a function and you want a
progress dialogue
well I mean nothing nothing like that
can be done with just Echo right I mean
you will have to enter and I mean that's
true for our progress monitors and that
will be true for your for your quick and
dirty progress monitor you will need to
have a variable that tracks the state
and your progress monitor however you
implement it will need to you know
print spit out values from that
monitored variable or variables well
except that I'd really love to have a
monitor for map for example even though
I don't have a you know I think we
talked about this before having a
version of monitor which has one
argument
yes
and we
um
was there
and we have a branch that does it
possibly in the Prototype build and I'm
trying to remember why it's not finished
the Lou was there some
I mean there was some problem around
message you know what happens with bad
arguments
um
that's the one that I remember Julio was
it Julia or Carlo it was Julio
mentioning yeah
um well maybe we could look at that
again
can we look at that again because it
seems like a very worthwhile thing to
have
all right let's just
right but but but I will I will point
out that you know
that doesn't just magically work right
monitor needs to be given the knowledge
to recognize oh this is map so let me
track this thing which is why I'm saying
Echo is not a progress monitor right it
will need to it can potentially Echo
things that are monitoring progress but
in and of itself it is
okay fair enough
so the only question is
when it echoes okay so let's think about
what happens usually Echo is just
extruding stuff up on the screen right
yep
so one thing we might want to do is to
penalize that stuff that is for example
that Echo is producing something that is
kind of like a limited size scroll on
the screen
yep I believe that was the thing of the
horror the idea of the horribly named
panel Echo right but an alternative to
that would be that there is a an echo
temporary that you call an echo
temporary but it has a second argument
which is the number of Echoes or
something
that's not quite the right thing that's
not the right thing it has to be Global
it's it's well okay
that's not quite the right thing
something has to be right I mean that
that could be like a second argument to
clean up Echo right that like you know
running Max goes to 10 or something
right it'll clean up everything at the
end but you right by default it'll show
everything and then clean everything up
at the end but you could say you know
running maximum is 10 and I like that I
like that that seems sensible to me and
that gets rid of the need for the panel
Echo thing
uh-huh
um so then we have the notion of echo
temporary
well the question is do we need to get
rid of the need for a limit Echo
and dollar Max Echo limit if it's just
the second argument to clean up Echo
what's Limited Echo
it's supposed to be you know basically
go after a certain number
I mean I think that there's a small
Corner case quite echo which is limit
Echo would work like messages do where
that particular message gets three
strikes and it's out
you see what I'm saying whereas cleanup
Echo by default
would not distinguish different echo
sources so it will just clean up you
know let's say you give it a depth of
five whatever those Echoes are it'll
it'll you know it'll only have five
total Echoes do you see what I'm saying
I'm not sure that decision is important
well that's certainly not what what that
putative documentation says right it
says limit Echo will evaluate expert
without letting Echo and related
functions print more than
max number of times yeah okay so it's
wrong but I mean but but you understand
what I'm saying you could limit it by
this particular piece of code can only
generate some number of of uh you know
as this piece of code is in a loop this
particular Echo can only appear more
than n times
uh less than n times right so okay so
you want something that that you know
basically it rather than limiting the
number that are kept it just stops
echoing after
yeah this particular Echo becomes
impotent so to speak after that number
of Echoes
right
um
the echo needs to literally
appear as a sub-expression of the expert
I mean right I don't know but I mean
this could certainly go into Echo
temporary this concept of a maximum
number if anybody cares about it the
maximum number per Echo
actually or it could go into quiet Echo
right well I you know once we either as
a right as an another option to quiet
Echo
which we you know right even if we don't
I don't know what does anybody else have
an opinion like Christopher do you have
an opinion about this is this a corner
case or is this case one cares about
I think it might be a case one cares
about because it might be
I don't know it's a corner case I mean
so you say I want 10 Echo a 10-day deep
Echo stack so to speak
and then you say oh my gosh I missed all
the ones like that I mean the mechanism
that we've had for the last 35 years for
messages
is reasonably sensible I think you know
three instances of one message and then
you see if there's something very
different happening
you see what I'm saying so that that's
not three instances of the same
message
the instances are the same the same
named message although a source might
have been lexically different
right
which I believe somebody suggested using
the label
the optional label for Echo as the as
that
basically like the message tag
one could
um I don't know in general I kind of
think that that Echoes are not meant for
you know
I I don't know I would kind of argue
that Echoes are are less meant for
building up giant systems and more just
for I'm debugging this or I need to add
some blogging here or something like
that exactly
but the first thing is when when there
is something absolutely irrelevant you
put an echo in a loop and it's scrolling
off the screen with crud
but then every so often there's an echo
you really care about and you lose it
because the the Irrelevant in a loop
Echo is drowning everything
right but you will right I mean that'll
happen no matter which way you limit it
it's good that's going to happen no it
isn't no it isn't if you limit by Echo
instance then the inner loop Echo can be
limited to five things and then it
limits out
and then you see the thing that is
important coming up later yeah but but
by at that point my claim is at that
point that's more trouble than it's
worth you'll run it runs you'll see that
it gets drowned out you'll remove the
thing that's drowning out in favor of
the thing that you actually care about
and then yeah possibly uh
so yeah I mean I
I I don't you know I you know I think we
should focus on
on things that were reasonably convinced
we need so I think we're reasonably
convinced that we want a dollar Echo
size limit yeah we're convinced that we
want an echo temporary because that's
just annoying to see the echo you know
because that way you can have that in a
notebook I've routinely like when I run
a notebook overnight for example okay
and I put an echo in there just so I can
you know you know so I can see roughly
what's happening right and I let it run
for another five hours
and the thing is just like gobs and gobs
of pages of Echoes which I really just
don't want once it's finished I just
want them all cleaned up
right
um now the only difference between
echo-temporary and cleanup Echo is that
I like to be able to have something
where I can just at the point where I'm
adding it to the code say it's a
temporary Echo
rather than having to wrap clean up and
go around the whole thing you can do
cleanup Echo around an entire input line
and it would effectively replace all of
the Echoes with Echo temporary yeah
exactly but but I think it's useful to
have the echo temporary
I well I guess I'm I'm going to disagree
with that because how often will you
want both
Echoes and Echo Temporaries
and right in which case why not just
have a slash slash cleanup Echo at the
end and then all of your you know you
can use all of the four types of Echoes
that we have that's not unreasonable
I don't disagree with that by the way
just as a provisional workaround and
maybe you're already doing this but I'll
remind you that you can option click in
Echo cell and that will select all the
echo cells in the notebook no I didn't
think of that
I never remember that we've had that
finish up for 35 years and I never
remember it
it's helpful
does anybody else know that anybody else
know that trick I know that I didn't I
use it daily
on echoes
I'm not sure how many people use it on
Echoes but I just checked and it works
fine on at least on the standard Echo
outputs I don't know if there are exotic
uh Echoes
yeah there's Echo timing and there's
Echo evaluation of different kinds of
echo cells yeah by the way the fact that
there are those different species of
echo is a great reason why Echo
temporary is a bad idea
mm-hmm
so all right so maybe it's clean up
echol I'm not so keen on the name and
that's the one function we we keep from
this whole collection
yeah and
okay yeah so dollar Echo size limit and
cleanup echo or Echo cleanup is that
better I'm not sure
yeah uh as soon as I said as soon as I
said it out loud I realized what is with
cleanup
how analogous is this to with cleanup
um
marginally yeah marginally right with
clean think of another word then clean
up
um
I mean it really is basically just
deleting Echoes at the end
right
it's temporary eyes Echo it could just
be it could just be remove Echo because
it's it's it's it's running at the end
what would be the function for this like
notebook delete
to delete a cell
yes yes right right and yeah I mean I
started to raise this question before
does it do the cleanup when the cleanup
echo or whatever we call it the remove
cleanup when it returns or when the
shift enter evaluation
returns because I think that's when it
returns I think it's much more useful
it's what when it returns because you
could have multiple blocks of stuff
okay and do this in between
but let's let's think about this name
for a second okay okay
um
let's see
uh
this sort of say a purge Echo
um
I mean
unfortunately
you know we don't really have a concept
I mean notebook delete
is obviously the same kind of concept
I think the problem is that cleanup like
that is a noun right I mean if we really
want it to be a verb that it should be a
camel case to clean up yeah and that's
really ridiculously confusing
let me see what would it be like delete
Echo
house
I think the Lydia Echo remove Echo yeah
I think I think that's more like delete
right because and then remove I mean we
typically use remove for
you know like we remove symbols we
remove if we could get away with delete
Echoes I think that would be somewhat
clear
would that be confusing with quiet Echo
why isn't it quiet echoes
okay what's some other words for delete
I mean it's um
trim truncate
oh I like trim yeah trim Echo
because
it's a bit confusing with go ahead
so each I was talking earlier about this
having an option to you know how many
keeps around
you know then I'm you know wondering
sort of how flexible is that bit of
functionality you know does it have the
ability to
allow the first three Echoes and then
drop everything after or you know as
well as keep the last three
yeah while it's displaying yeah I think
it probably does have um you know and
you know and can it be something where
you know
you know there's some set you know that
it deletes
it allows things to build up while it's
running and then you know keeps the last
three or something even after it's gone
I was thinking the same thing I think I
think whatever if this is a option for
um cleanup Echo we should have the same
option for quiet Echo and that should be
the thing that
them in The Notebook
right and quiet Echo could not
completely quiet it it could be you know
quiet with some escapees
all right let's think about this word I
mean we've got
okay what word
indicates we're going to
how about this how about erase Echo
seems better than any of the previous
ones it's somewhat clear that it's a
different kind of action
is there any sound related word
hash or something
we've already got quiet
[Music]
what were you saying sorry what were you
saying Jose
I was trying to find other sound related
given that Echo has this as this
immediate connection with sound
like mute
yeah except mute would be better for
quiet I mean
yeah but it isn't really the same thing
it's after the fact
you see it doesn't really a thing for
sound because in sound I went yak yak
yak but I can't un Yak my Yaks so to
speak
once heard it cannot be unheard
but once written it could be erased
I like a race Echo it's interesting that
we have never used any form of a race in
a system symbol before
that is interesting
well why why would we use a race to not
delete
[Music]
good question
because we don't want to sound like
we're supporting Cybermen
what
these Cybermen uh I remember when they
were first on television yeah well and
they're the very actually when they
actually were were airing
um they uh they like to uh delete their
enemies yeah the the new Doctor Who
series they've uh like Daleks they now
have a a you know a word they've latched
onto which is delete
oh I don't know they had that in 1965.
they did not have it in the original
series that's new to the to the to the
2000 series I see
um
Lily Techo is not obviously bad
I think we should go with that now let's
talk options for a minute
I was gonna say John so we've never had
a race but we had clean slate which
I don't think that that wasn't ever in
the system context though no it was a
package you know that's
you know basically you know reset your
Global State and everything and
yeah that went back to Babylonian times
they have slices I don't know
the they did it have slates so they just
have clay tablets
I don't know when Sleepless in in Roman
times they like their wax their wax
tablets huh
this isn't like block Echo
interesting question
that's an interesting question
I don't think so I think it's more if
it's any of those things it's um
what's that is it sort of like block
random
yeah but it's not block random in the
sense that it's like a dynamic module
where it returns
because it's a visible thing on the
screen
it is deleting really the only operation
we want to support here might you want
to copy all your Echoes somewhere else
as the as a cheap modeling about this
let's talk about this
right that that is one of the things
under goals of you know of do we want to
redirect Echoes yes let's talk about
that because that's another support like
print action
well we could call it control Echo
it sounds a bit like quiet Echo but but
let's talk about what to do with the
redirection
because we do want to have some
mechanism for just sending all the
echoes
somewhere where did we want to send them
to a file
that's the primary place
I think it would probably be some subset
of the things that are supported by
print action
what is supported by production
I'm not sure
messages window I think
what the heck is it
it's front-end option I it's one that I
have an updated documentation before to
look at something I was just
doing a live stream and somebody asked
when this was
oh I said 20 years and I'm wrong it's
it's only a 13.
anyway
um okay
what do we really want this to do if I
mean basically it's it's a logging
function
and I'm not sure that we should have
the problem is we don't want all the
Echoes we've got so many different
echoes
you know we might have a different
function called log Echo I don't think
it's quite the same thing cleaning it up
and logging it
unless you say it should no because we
don't want to display first and only put
it to the file later if you get what I'm
saying
I mean I think logging is something
different
tie it up with that go except that
the actions that we have at Echo like
Echo evaluation and things like this
seem very useful for logging
can you look at the options for print
action in the global preferences
which global preferences option
inspector command shift o
it's the format here it's right there
middle
change the scope to Global
and pop open the menu
but these are all very notebook oriented
though
I mean to me this is more like the
deployment of a form notebook or
something
right what could you do okay what could
you do with the log you could log to a
fi okay
where can you log
you could log to local object
you could log to a dated bin
Maybe
you could log to a cloud object
you could log to a file
you could just log a memory
how do you retrieve it
all right or you could log to well I
mean it's it's you know I mean it's it's
like a so reap sort of thing right
why aren't you using sewing rate compute
if you want to actually
split out an expression use so on reap
could be a time right and like going
into some Global association with uh
timestamps as keys
that would be a way to
yes to log to memory
it could be pretty much vulnerable to
aborts
okay
yeah so whoever was just speaking was
sorry my mic was dead or Jeremy okay
yeah uh my mic was up sorry I was saying
that
um using an association is less
vulnerable to aborts than using so and
reap
that's a good point
right question okay
so
I have to say that I think the echo
framework is a pretty reasonable
framework for saying what you put in a
log file but maybe I'm wrong
I mean otherwise how would we log
evaluations for example or timings
or would we have a actually there's
another possibility like event handlers
we could have or Handler functions we
could have something which basically
logs there's all kinds of keys available
for the logger
so and we could have a thing which says
um
log evaluate or something
um what's the right word I mean log
obviously is taken
um
so the concept would be it's a logging
of X bar
comma and then a bunch of keys
and then it logs those keys
sorry I got disconnected
it logs those attributes so it could be
for example logging
you know it could be time stamp
time
evaluation time
it could be
uh
input
held input or something
this is a better idea by the way output
Etc memory
well I mean the other thing one could do
is just log
when it gives an arbitrary expression to
specify what to log
so it could either be the now you can
log the now
it's not too easy to log the evaluation
time because that requires something
that sort of spans the expert
but I mean then this would be
basically this would be some kind of
default logging
okay what would one do here what would
one do one log by session one could log
by session to a local option one could
log in a directory I mean that's what a
lot of applications might do log into a
directory with a uuid
guys
sorry can you repeat the question
where does it log by default do you have
to specify the logging location every
time or does it simply log
you know is there a Dollar logging
location
which is simply set globally where you
expect that all logging in a session
goes to the same place
do you understand what I'm saying I mean
one possibility you know at least on you
know depending on the platform is
you know wherever the global system log
is
yes
well yeah assuming there are user logs
maybe there are user logs on all
platforms now I mean right it can't be
the global system one because that won't
normally be writable by the user
um
right right whichever one on Mac OS that
I you know
random apps logging you to it yeah the
one that's until till day the one that's
in till day Library logs rather than
slash Library logs
questions do we want a computable log
that would be more like a data bin
I mean if it was a data bin it would be
a computable log
it's just a piece of text it's not a
computable log but in and of itself
well okay I guess one you know potential
difference between Echo and logging is
that
you know Echo you're probably interested
in the results of a computation whereas
logging you're probably just as likely
to be interested in what the input was
sure
I know that's why I think we need these
keys
well I think also
right I mean I feel like with Echo you
right Echo is typically not something
you want to keep around right whereas
logging is probably some maybe something
you do want to keep around
yes
it's not totally obvious you don't want
to keep that car around I've seen plenty
of use cases where you do
look I think we should Implement delete
Echo where the second argument which
will also be at some value you know also
its operator form
that is a count of some kind
and let us account on the and that's the
running total
that's the number that you the number of
survivors so the default will be zero I
see
um
okay
right so then you say right so that
allows you to see the last five
which is an argument for calling it
prune Echo
Maybe
how do people feel about prune versus
delete
what's that I think I prefer delete
we can't implement this delete let's see
what that feels like so you say delete
oh five and that would show you that
would leave as residue in the notebooks
the last five echoes
right
so were you thinking the second argument
is I think it charity delete echo of X
bar comma n
or the sub-value would be
delete echov and
Expo okay
so that would require just that wait a
minute does that work or is that
impossible because of no um no held sub
values
exactly we need to hold all sub values
to do the sub-value case yeah so you
know what we can Implement immediately
is delete that covers I think it might
be nicer to have delete echo of xper one
argument just have a reasonable
no I think it should delete everything I
think it should get rid of everything
same as quiet Echo basically yeah
yeah it's a quiet at the end
it's a see it but
you know see it but delete it
yeah I think this is why Utah suggested
for this is similar to The Quiet Echo
suggestion itai had but it was an option
so that you didn't have the you could
still have a one argument form and a
hold all sub value right
I see what you're saying
yeah you're not entirely wrong there
oh boy okay yeah I agree
um there's even there's even the whole
notion of you know logging levels and I
don't know if that would even should
even become Echo levels where it's you
know the it's always there but it's only
enabled when you want debugging level as
opposed to error level or something like
that
that's more for quiet Echo
The Echoes are there but they're quieted
I mean it's something I do reasonably
often you how that goes in the code but
you're too quiet to Echo
right but the point is that
um you don't want to quiet all the
Echoes no I got it I got it again so you
have tags in The Echoes and you say
right yeah
I can see that being useful but I mean
this is look this is in the department
of error handling basically of similar
kinds of things of some amount of code
automation
all right look I think we've got some
path forward here I agree those are some
ideas that we should consider but let's
[Music]
um
I mean having tags on Echoes is a whole
nother thing which reminds me of tags on
messages right it's like the verbosity
level story
which unfortunately as we've seen many
times one person's you know I don't care
about that messages another person's
golden message
I'm making sense but I liked your idea
about Echo label because that's that
basically means that now the logging
levels are user or Echo levels or user
defined instead of
um
well well you mentioned Echo label after
I was talking about levels and so the
idea ends so so I interpreted that as an
idea of
um quiet Echo taking an optional second
argument where you give it the pattern
that should be quieted and then if your
Echoes are actually Echo labels then the
pattern matches the label no I said I
didn't think of that but yes that wasn't
what I was thinking of but it's a good
idea
you're suggesting quiet Echo takes a
pattern
and so then it's up to you to make a
convention for how you quiet things you
want to quiet exactly
it's not a crazy idea
what does squat Echo do right now in
terms of that
this is one argument
could take a pattern
and one day it could yeah it could take
apart all right so look that's an
interesting solution to that problem
we've still got the logging thing which
I think is probably for a separate
discussion
uh a subtle question so it it's uh for
Echo evaluation each Echo evaluation
prints twice so does that count as one
or two echoes
for things that take a number of Echoes
I think it's one Echo I think it's every
Echo call not everybody I was going to
argue you it should be well okay it's
all complicated I was gonna argue for
you too because when you set sort of
your limit what you're really trying to
set is how much space it's going to take
up on your screen yes but on the other
hand if you like one problem
right right if you if you tell it you
know I have you know I can only have
five Echoes on my screen then it's kind
of unclear what to do
yeah I think it has to be a one lump
because otherwise you can't limit it you
can't limit in half
half
you know Echo pairs
right I don't think it'll be too tragic
I mean it's just like a log file and
you're only looking at a window in it
it's fine that you're missing some
pieces but well okay so then we have to
have a visual indicator that we're
missing something a vertical dot dot dot
or something like that
how would we do that
and what happens if you've got a print
followed by Echoes to The Echoes just
vanish
so your notebook so if you have a print
echo echo echo print echo echo echo and
then some of the earlier Echoes expire
then they disappear right they think
[Music]
right you're deleting The Echoes and
prints live in their own place right
yeah okay fine so they just disappear in
the notebook Scrolls
yep yep
um
okay and then
then you're claiming that the
disappearance of Echoes it leaves no
residue
correct yeah I think you're right
it's a little odd because you know in
the print world in the in the message
world
the final thing waves a flag and says
I'm done
is there any grin of the Cheshire Cat
that should be left so to speak
I mean the first one
right the first Echo
uh uh or or I guess the third Echo
you know the the last Echo that Prince
could also say something like hey I'm
not gonna be printing anymore
I mean I think a difference between the
two cases is that in the case of
messages
you don't necessarily know where they're
coming from
whereas in the case of Echoes it's much
more likely that
you're in control of them and you know
that you've done delete Echo
and that things may be pruned right it's
very rare that I don't know where an
echo is coming from and if I'm in a
situation where I'm confused I use Echo
label or some such so then I know
exactly where each Echo is coming from
well that's because you're assuming Echo
is a local debugging Loop not something
that somebody's put into a piece of
production code nobody should ever put
Echo into production code I was gonna
say can I start putting echoes in
production good
right okay fine so
the other the other issue is that the
prince the message stuff deletes from
the end whereas the echo stuff deletes
from the beginning
right the echo thing is a stack
basically or something it's a stack but
it's something where no it's a it's a
you know least recently used
you know it it removes the things that
haven't been recently used
right so what you'll see is that it will
eat itself from the top
so you're thinking delete Echo with five
specified will have five of the most
recent things yes absolutely
that's the most useful thing for it to
do
anybody object to that no I mean right
and this is why I mean we I guess we've
moved away from this suggestion right
but I did suggest an option of like
running Max or something where it
right it lops off
where you see the five most recent or
the 10 most recent ones I mean we could
have -5 be the last detail and five with
the head
you know
well I mean that
you know introduces another possible
name of you know tail echo or something
the tail is gone the animal left the
building you know
no I mean I'm you know talking about you
know in terms of like you know Unix
command line head and tail yeah I
understand that I understand that my
point is
that
at the end of it
wait a minute tail well I guess you
don't end tail if the process exits is
there a tail left over
well I mean that that that that that's a
meaningless question right whatever the
process wrote to to you know Tails input
stream the last five things will be
shown
okay so the tail the animal did not
leave the building is what I'm saying
that there's a piece of tail left over
at the end correct whereas the default
case of delete Echo there is no tail
left over correct everything's gone yes
should quiet Echo also be the same
I mean I'm wondering if these really
want to be options rather than optional
arguments right it's like
keep
we could have like two options right
keep from beginning and keep from end so
it's really cloudy I think we should use
plus and minus for that because we've
got such so many kinds right so then
what's the name of the option
why does it have to be an optional why
isn't it an argument
well I because I oh well well I guess my
belief is that it's more common that
you'd want to the last five than you'd
want the first five in which case it's
weird it's weird if the default is to
use negative values but it's also weird
if we reverse the sense of positive and
negative
laughs
I'll start I think delete echo of expert
one argument using zero as the default
is uh
is better
well I think I think we all agree on
that point the the questions
how would it then work it was -5 you
couldn't do that what if
okay so delete Echo your option or
argument or whatever
take span syntax
of what it's going to trim out
what does zero mean
well this is it all if it turns
everything
all all is terms everything
you know colon colon
minus five
that's incredibly obscure
I mean semicolon semicolon -5 would mean
everything up to
I guess what is the notation of our
audio trim
you know if we wanted to use the trim
name we should at least make sure you
know what the
I think the original one was really
image to him rather than audio trim or
you're taking forever to run
okay so audio trim
um
well I get I guess I I like audio trim
as a better template because it I think
of it as linear unlike image trim uh but
um right so audio trim I mean right if
we called it right and the default is to
trim everything at the end
um
and uh
yeah I think audio trim with the second
argument Echo trim with a second
argument actually makes a fair amount of
sense
sorry Echo trim with what tramaco why is
it or
what's that well trim Echo what are you
suggesting all right I'm saying that
trim Echo with a second argument
you know make make sense
which is then right whether to keep
anything from the beginning or end
well so what is it from the end we would
not have the holdall sub value in that
case right
yeah I guess that's true I mean that
that is right if it's not an option
then we can't have the operator form the
whole thing is if it is an option the
operator form is still rocky because
that's assuming you never want to Echo
blah Arrow blah
we have plenty of precedent for things
where you know where uh where options
you know that rules the rules that are
valid option names are treated
especially I know this is a slightly
awkward case
because I think Echo is a somewhat
General function I think there are other
cases where it's really un you know
undangerous
uh you mean like uh
string uh string functions where you
have
you know string arguments
it's
I I I don't buy that argument we have
plenty of uh or you know plenty of cases
the the and you know right uh arguments
options right has an option to control
the behavior this way of whether
so
it's common enough we automated it
yeah okay
I have to run in a second here
um
uh
well let me see
um I'll confess that I'm a little bit
confused about which function or
functions we've decided to keep or maybe
we haven't decided yet no we decided
we're keeping delete echo or some
version of delete Tech or trim Echo okay
and and that's the only one other than
the other other than dollar
Echo size limit size limit okay the only
two we're keeping
and we know the functionality we want
for the elite Echo we just don't know
quite how to achieve it that is we want
keep the first five
you know the last five
I don't think we want
and the question of how exactly how we
sub-value you know whatever it is is
still open
and we also need a separate discussion
about logging
okay okay
and that I think is it
okay you need to run
um
right
so see you guys thanks